the angle does not often quote the folks
over at salon they've trashed us a few
times but an interesting piece today
nevertheless noting the cozy
relationship between neocons who are
once nominally republicans and the
current crop of the biden administration
foreign policy team and if he were
looking to cool things down in ukraine
biden's utterance of genocide certainly
didn't help here now is glenn greenwald
the pulitzer prize-winning journalist
whose work can be found in sub-stack
glenn your reaction to all of this and i
can't believe i'm citing salon maybe the
worlds are colliding here
well it's not any less surprising the
fact that neocons seem to be
the most beloved and admired and
influential people within not just the
democratic party but also american
liberalism given that they were their
arch enemies 10 to 15
years ago and this is the most
extraordinary part of it laura is that
when we talk about neocons we're not
just talking about people who wanted to
go to war in afghanistan or wanted to go
to war in iraq large majorities of
americans wanted that in the wake of 9
11 which is a very traumatic attack on
our country but most people many people
came to realize pretty quickly wait a
minute this war seems to have no real
purpose it doesn't actually have an end
it's not actually improving the lives of
the american people neocons never came
to that realization they loved those
wars they think we should have had more
afghanistans in iraq and so they were
discredited by the end of the bush
administration into the obama
administration and largely because they
rebranded themselves as opponents to
trump
vicious vehement steadfast opponents of
trump they were able to rehabilitate
their reputation with liberals and now
they become the leading voices again on
foreign policy
among not just liberals and and
democrats but also those kind of old
standard militaristic republicans who
never learned the lessons of iraq and
afghanistan and they're not just back
but they're they're leading the way you
see the result
yeah and the liberals i mean used to be
kind of for peace right i mean that's
out the window now
yeah i mean look
you you you look at the war in ukraine
and obviously you're horrified by a lot
of the images that you've seen and
that's because all wars
involve atrocities all wars involved
hideous images and and and complete
mistreatment of human beings the
question that we were supposed to ask
with afghanistan and iraq but never did
is what is the purpose of this war how
does it end
what is our answer to this war what is
it that we don't know when how do we end
we don't have an answer glenn they don't
want to answer the question and thank
you for posing it tonight it's great to
see you hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else